will you please state your name
yes it's amber laura hurd her ex-husband
had given evidence now this was amber
heard's turn
i struggle to find the words to describe
how
painful this is
this is the most painful and difficult
thing i've ever gone through
she set out how their romance began on
the press tour for the 2011 film they
made together a whirlwind of passion and
lavish gifts
when i was around johnny i felt like the
most beautiful person in the world
you know made me feel seen made me feel
like a million dollars
interspersed with depp's drinking binges
and signs of his controlling behavior
he would make these comments about
you know
pouring myself out but do so in the
context of
me acting
every
time i was walking out of the house i
he would ask me that's really what
you're wearing kid you know like when
i'm standing there you know just hit the
wall screaming at me
um
but
then he would um disappear
and get clean and sober and he'd come
back and tell me
that he
was done drinking
the first time he'd hit her she claimed
was after she'd laughed at his tattoo
he slaps me one more time
hard
i lose my balance um at this point we're
sitting next to each other on the edge
of the couch i was on the edge of the
couch
and
i'm
all of a sudden
realizing that the worst thing has just
happened to me
that could possibly happen to you i
realized that i
i wish so much he had said he was
joking because it didn't hurt
didn't physically hurt me
i was just sitting there on this on this
carpet looking at the dirty carpet
wondering how i wound up on this carpet
and why i was
never why i never noticed that the
carpet was so filthy before and i just
didn't know what else to do i didn't
know what to say i didn't know how to
react i just
sat there thinking how much time do i
have to i figure out what i
need to do because god did he just hit
me
the court also heard graphic details of
a sexual assault she said she suffered
as depp searched her body claiming she
was hiding cocaine from him
he was looking he said he was looking
for his drugs his cocaine his coke while
derp in his evidence has claimed he was
in fact the victim of domestic violence
heard has said at his worst she feared
him but was too scared to leave
katie spencer sky news